ic et spécialiste de l'émission nous
faire des commentaires sur sa non parce
que c'était vraiment vous allez être là
tous les mardis pour nous faire une
petite analyse alors moi je suis
clairement fans de cette émission je la
trouvais z l'info que je donnais c'est
que malheureusement ce garçon qui avait
l'air très gentil s'est fait tuer inondé
d' insulte sur les réseaux sur celle
admise cause de quoi son polo rouge à
cause de sa barbiche dur c'est mal je
trouve ça vraiment mais ô dieu parce que
la valeur très bon calibre vraiment s'il
vous plaît sur les réseaux soyez un peu
cool parce que moi j'ai quand même
l'impression que sur twitter on a fait
le condensé de tous les cons de france
et on les a lus sur twitter et ça
commence à être un supporter qui
auraient été jugées physique
arrêtez de juger s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît j'en peux plus d'entendre des
conneries aussi pareil comme ça je vous
le dis au total s'il vous plaît aussi
on se calme là parce que là twitter je
suis désolé moi je vous dire twitter
c'est un outil exceptionnel pour les
médias ces séances est ainsi passé au ps
c'est bon si vous voulez pas être connu
et qui voulait pas si vous voulez que
quand sur twitter vous arrivez vous ayez
que des vous êtes la plus belle rogner
êtes la meilleure
non mais vous êtes la meilleure vous
êtes la plus belle ce que tu fais c'est
génial tu es toujours magnétique et bien
vous allez pas ou plutôt votre sujet
cyril s'il vous plaît on parle d'un
garçon qui s'était harcelé par la
critique constructive n'a pas accepté le
physique des gens là-bas sujet non mais
lui n'a rien demandé mais je reviens à
6,7 sur twitter mais je vous dire vous
êtes juste tu m'avais page unis et sur
twitter forcément il ya c'est comme dans
la vie sûr il ya des choses non c'est
bien gentil c'est comme dans la vie
c'est ensuite laissés par les autres
vous avez parlé depuis deux heures donc
on n'est pas d'accord non mais t'as
essayé et on veut laisser parler sa cage
il ya stefania tout le monde on fait pas
d'émission à 2 donc si vous payez gilles
verdez kelly franchement vous pouvez
avoir une analyse critique sur la
manière dont twitter juge le physique de
quelqu'un mais globalisé les assurant de
votre part je trouve ça hyper décevant
et moi j'adore le faire
c'est moi finir venir twitter un
individu égale un autre tout le monde
d'avoir droit à la connaissance tout le
monde peut s'exprimer que ce soit bien
qu'on vous aime ou qu'on vous aime pas
on a le droit de s'exprimer du moment
qu'on le déplace pas ça vers le terrain
de l'insultent vous ne pouvez pas dire
que twitter est un mois facebook et
twitter c'est ouvert je suis ok moi pour
moi twitter c'est un outil incroyable et
oui et je vous dire ça me permet de
garder le contact a bien vu plein de
gens que je vois pas en ce moment plein
de gens qui nous regardent
plein de gens à qui je laisse des
messages médecins de gens qui me laisse
des messages avec qui je garde le
contact on peut pas avoir deux publics
en ce moment ici donc moi les réseaux
sociaux pour ça je peux vous dire c'est
hyper important et ça me permet de
garder le contact avec les
téléspectateurs avec plein de gens qui
me manque
et j'espère à qui je manque et twitter
n'y a pas que du mauvais temps les
métiers fournil saint baudile étiez vous
avez qui paie pour ça oui vous êtes vous
m'avez gars sont là oui oui mais oui le
twitter et ben c'est pas le faire si
vous avez vous avez tous les deux raison
vous avez tous les deux raison oui quand
même si ils ont tous les deux raison ce
pauvre garçon il d'un seul coup y est
exposé et se fracasser sur twitter et
c'est vrai que c'est un des réseaux
sociaux qui est le plus fracassant
mais en ces gens là où civile a raison
c'est que nous vous si on y est qu'on
s'est fracassée si la personne c'est
normal c'est son jeu on s'embrasse et le
jeu voilà
mais c'est là où tu as raison aussi
c'est que ce garçon n'est pas prêt à ça
allait mais chéri
non